bring that in foul Wow world's greatest
artist this is one of those achievements
that you sit there and you tell people
that you're gonna win of course you know
you never really think you are but by
god Here I am I guess I won I don't know
it's not a big deal I went a lot of
stuff so this is really nothing to me
this means everything to me after all
the hard work that I put in and whatever
it is that I do oh my god actually feels
a lot lighter it's true oh my god it's
true that it's so heavy it's so much
heavier looks like a shitty trophy
anyway I don't even want it i want to
thank no one for this award i did this
all on my lonesome so now but I'm
holding this in my hand I can find it
mr. suck it mother I just
my girlfriend wanted me to thank her
that's a big note for me I just want to
say thank you to my fans my wife my kids
I would like to thank my parents for
conceiving me first of all there's so
many names my brother-in-law my
brother's sister my sister-in-law and
water and food for keeping me alive
shelter has been okay for the most part
just one second don't don't blame you if
I just want to thank I am the best in
this category this year because I am the
world's greatest artist weathers drawing
being comedic being hilarious thanks
again to Earth Mother Earth for creating
life and sustaining it and it's a
magical cyclical glory I feel like I
could trade this for a lot of cocaine
and and and it'll like it's it's worth a
lot in cocaine oh my gosh Kony 2012
we're gonna find him someday really it's
all about the PR that is doing the PR
behind the Oscars so thank you so much
I'm gonna go enjoy this thanks whatever
it is I'm an artist on the greatest I go
oh is that the music playing the music's
playing so I got to wrap this up just
kidding thanks guys I appreciate it good
seriously you sent me of this shoot it's
not even real gold trophy it's my age a
nice piece of [ __ ] his name is Ricky
she's actually my producer also if you
want to get him fired click like on all
my videos and I'll firearm